[Music]
in a world where zombies have already
infected every facet of pop culture
comes another zombie movie but this time
it's got Brad Pitt World War Z get ready
for the big screen adaptation of the
best-selling novel that's got everything
you loved about the title and nothing
else a filled with so many production
problems people were genuinely surprised
when it wasn't a complete disaster
meet Jerry Lane he's just your average
everyday super attractive scarf wearing
Spanish speaking airplane piloting
sharpshooting skull bashing armour
crafting arm chop a prisoner
interrogating surgery doing slo-mo
vision having ended up making eagle-eyed
stay-at-home dad travel the globe with
Brad Pitt and a film screenwriters as
they stumble from said piece - said -
he's tied together by the flimsiest
evidence ever there was a memo sent from
this installation had the word zombie in
it do you know anything about it there's
an email not a memo come on watch Brad
Pitt survive and unsurvivable apocalypse
thanks to a constant stream of
life-saving coincidences like never
hitting traffic in the middle of mass
hysteria finding an RV with the keys and
a loaded gun inside this friendly mugger
showing him where to find medicine this
friendly Mexican family taking him in no
questions asked these fast zombies who
slow down as soon as they're about to
catch him this small child had shutting
a zombie on top of him this plane
dropping a ladder down to save him it'd
take off this Israeli soldier killing a
zombie about to eat him surviving this
car crash surviving this plane crash
surviving the spike to his stomach and
shooting up with a randomly picked virus
that happens to be curable while also
serving zombie camouflage wait is that
Matthew Fox so get ready for a
by-the-numbers action movie full of
pg-13 violence and none of these awesome
things from the book
[Music]
then what a waste of good source
material starring the zombie movie
cliches - head car batteries
flickering lights shaky-cam jumpscares
zombies bay doors a kid with asthma
accidental noises Tori
inception was
Brad Pitt zombie movie man all those
reshoots must have cost a fortune
oddly paper that
[Music]
man that really makes me want a coke
thanks for watching be sure to subscribe
this is my boomstick Duff man can't
breathe oh no there can be only one it's
a trap you are not the father and all
the girlies say I'm pretty fly white guy